para ver la diferencia entre la
contabilidad de caja y la contabilidad
de efectivo haré el siguiente pequeño
ejemplo pero voy a empezar explicando
las cosas utilizando la intuición que es
como manejamos el efectivo a diario y
después voy a llevar a esto a cómo
funcionaría en lo laboral y para poder
entender un poco del contexto del dinero
en efectivo cómo es en la vida diaria
pues esto sucede cuando nosotros
recibimos dinero de algún cliente o de
alguna situación con lo que contamos la
medida del ingreso dependiendo de un
tiempo determinado pues si juntamos
gastos e ingresos y checamos cuán caro
nos sale el evento podemos sacar la
ganancia dependiendo de todos estos
elementos y la mayoría de los negocios
se basan así en cuanto al dinero en
efectivo pues esto nos da como una
visión como una especie de árbol donde
nos permite ver claramente todos los
gastos y todos los ingresos de una mejor
manera en un cierto periodo
ahora bien pasando al ejemplo y
utilizando la intuición del dinero en
efectivo asumamos que vamos a iniciar
sin capital y que el costo para poder
atender el evento para nosotros será de
100 dólares y que el cliente pagará por
nuestros servicios
200 dólares entonces esto sería que
ellos nos pagan estos 200 dólares por
adelantado y aquí pondré
luego que sean los gastos aquí pondré a
100 dólares que podrían ocuparse como
para nuestro salario o algún tipo de
inversión que se necesitará como egreso
para proporcionar nosotros la atención y
lo que pondré aquí ahora serían las
ganancias pero voy a poner con color
verde entonces serían aquí los 100
dólares de ganancia y tendríamos más
abajo 100 dólares que nos quedan en
efectivo y todo esto finalmente sería en
cuanto hablemos del primer mes porque
ahora yendo a nuestro segundo mes aquí
el precio para atender el evento nos
saldría en 200 dólares por lo que
acuerdas con tu cliente que él pague 400
dólares pero para el mes siguiente
entonces al utilizar nosotros estos 200
dólares que los ocupamos para la
atención digamos que hemos sobregirado
el dinero por lo que esto lo voy a
escribir de manera negativa y serán como
números rojos pues gastamos 200 dólares
y no hay ningún ingreso que lo cubra en
nuestra base de efectivo pues el cliente
no nos estará pagando en este mes ellos
nos darán los 400 dólares hasta el mes
siguiente y anteriormente en nuestro
efectivo en nuestra base de efectivo
teníamos 100 dólares
acumulado de los 200 que nos pagaron
adelantadamente pero esto no alcanza
para cubrir gastos de este mes por lo
que no tenemos ingresos en este periodo
ya esto es a lo que yo le llamo el
sobregiro en nuestras raíces contables
porque aquí al final vamos a tener menos
100 dólares y bueno esto es lo que
ocurre en nuestro segundo mes donde no
recibimos ningún ingreso ahora si nos
vamos al tercer mes aquí vamos a recibir
los 400 dólares del cliente del mes
anterior y también recibiremos 200
dólares por adelantado del cliente del
mes siguiente y como podemos observar
juntos estos 400 dólares y estos 200
dólares hacen una buena cantidad pues el
hecho de haber recibido junto el dinero
del cliente del mes anterior y el del
mes siguiente es apoyo para poder quitar
nuestros números rojos pues son 600
dólares que se van a nuestro capital
contable de efectivo los cuales nos
llevan a un buen equilibrio porque
finalmente tendríamos 500 dólares por
los menos 100 que debíamos del mes
anterior entonces ahora me voy al cuarto
mes esto
nos va a costar 100 dólares a atender el
evento el cual lo voy a anotar por aquí
pero este es el mismo color entonces voy
a poner un color magenta y serán 100
dólares que nos está costando atender el
evento entonces como en este mes no hay
ingresos puesto que se pagaron en meses
previos éstos aparecerán como una
pérdida por lo que finalmente tendríamos
400 dólares de capital en efectivo y lo
voy a poner por aquí abajo y así de
simple luce este modelo de bases de
efectivo contable el cual se utiliza en
la gran mayoría de los negocios pero
muchas veces no es tan efectivo pues las
ganancias como puedes ver van variando a
veces son buenas a veces bajas y quizás
no tan rentables pero algunos negocios
resulta que si son estables y les
funciona este modelo